[Music]
anna joins us in nyc anna welcome to the
show
hi um how are you good how are you
um i'm good i'm in a bit of a sticky
situation
so i have
180 thousand dollars worth of student
loans
and that's undergrad and grad loans
together
and so they're comprised of a few
different ones with different
percent interests and as of may first
i'm supposed to start paying them back
um and i recently started working
making about a hundred thousand per year
that's come from and i'm not
yeah so i'm not renting yet um but i'm
also
moving out of my family's house which
i've been living at since colvin
so that's going to be
an expense
added on as well and i'm just very lost
in how to
handle these loans i'm not sure if i
should refinance or consolidate or do
income based repayment
um so i was hoping to get your advice on
that yeah well at the end of the day
there's only one way to get rid of debt
and that's to get rid of debt and so i
don't like consolidation and refinance
as a shortcut because it's not a
shortcut you're just moving the debt
around and feeling like you did
something and so the best thing you can
do
is use the debt snowball method to
attack these debts are you familiar with
that
um a little bit
so um i think you you tackle
this uh i forgot if it was the smallest
or the largest loans smallest so here's
what you're going to do okay you're
going to ignore the interest rate i know
that hurts because you're a smart woman
and you go you look at the interest rate
and it makes you want to throw up right
yeah it's about six percent right now
which is terrifying and i'm i was hoping
to get that down to
4
which a lot of these refinancing
companies offer but i don't know if
that's the way to go
well i mean it's worth a shot if you
want to look at that our friends at
splash financial they're they're good
people and you can check with them to
see what you could do i don't mind it
when you can lower the interest rate i
just don't want you to extend the length
of the loan
so sometimes what they'll do is they'll
go yeah we'll give you four percent but
now you're in debt even longer and your
your payments higher and so there's all
kinds of things they can do to kind of
trick you into thinking that you got a
deal
so i would check with splash but really
at the end of the day i still want you
to do the debt snowball i don't want you
to consolidate this because what happens
is it becomes one giant mountain and
it's unbearable versus feeling the
progress freeing up each payment as you
pay it off so what i would do is you can
use the debt snowball calculator on our
website
and you can actually put in all of your
debts from smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate just
ignore that and we're going to start
paying off the smallest one with a
vengeance so make minimum payments on
all of the other student loans you can
afford to do that right come may
um
yeah i i will i don't know what what the
payment would be
um if i
because uh there's a lot of individual
loans there's actually about like 23 to
be exact
yeah well the good news is they're
probably all fairly small especially at
the front end yeah yeah yeah there's
there's a few really huge ones and then
there's a bunch that are about a
thousand or a thousand five hundred yeah
now when you move out are you gonna get
a roommate
yeah so i already signed a lease
actually for may first as well um and my
expense there will be about 1500 which
i'm sure sounds crazy but it's new york
so it's kind of standard
um
so i don't know even how much
i
could be paying off
um while also you know
living in new york city as well and and
i'm not like a big fender by any means
i'm ready to just like
eat rice and beans for a while yeah
you're going to continue living like a
broke college student because you're
broke right now thanks to these student
loans
now
what kind of work are you doing
i'm a software engineer oh awesome
well yeah hopefully your income will
continue to go up
yeah it's my first software engineering
job so
i'm hoping it'll obviously only go up
from here is it remote or is it in the
office it's hybrid so it's two days
remote three days in the office okay
well i know in the software engineer
world in that tech world you can
leapfrog when it comes to income when
you move to this company and that
company and all of a sudden you could be
making two three hundred thousand in
that
world right that's definitely the goal
so use that to your advantage as you
start this kind of new chapter with a
roommate live like you're broke and if
you can do that i mean the 1500 a month
is going to eat up a good chunk of your
income but beyond that if you can throw
you know 60
70k of debt at the debt you can be done
with this thing i want you to be done in
two years anything beyond that i'm going
this is just two years this is too long
well that's 90 000 a year that's 90 000
a year obviously it's not possible with
your current income and current living
situation but let's say you worked fully
remote and you could move somewhere less
expensive or move you know across the
bay or whatever that looks like for you
and you hustled and you did some side
hustling with your software engineer
skills you brought in an extra 20k these
are the kind of sacrifices that you're
gonna have to make if you want to climb
out of this hole and you don't want it
to be a slog of seven years and you're
still trying to pay off these student
loans and you're still trying to mess
around with consolidation to fix the
problem we gotta rip the band-aid off
and look at the hard numbers but i'm
telling you the debt snowball is your
best path to do it you're gonna feel the
progress you're gonna free up payments
along the way and you're going to see
the light at the end of the tunnel hang
on i'm going to have kelly give you
ramsey plus one year membership to help
walk with you along this journey and you
call us back if we can do anything else
to help you thanks for the call